(upbeat music)
- What's up, everybody? Michael here.
It's been nearly a decade
since the most infamous
restaurant review of all time.
It included classic zingers,
like how the blue watermelon margarita
"tastes like some combination
of radiator fluid and formaldehyde."
And the one that asks: "Why
is one of the few things
on your menu that can be
eaten without fear or regret
called a roasted pork banh mi
when it resembles that item
about as much as you
resemble Emily Dickinson?"
The review in question eviscerated
Guy's American Kitchen and
Bar, owned by Guy Fieri.
The review-slash-assassination
attempt was penned
by "New York Times"
restaurant critic Pete Wells.
When it came out in 2012,
Fieri had already been a Food
Network star for six years
with several seasons of "Guy's Big Bite"
and "Diners, Drive-Ins,
and Dives" under his belt.
He also owned four successful restaurants.
Today, "Diners, Drive-Ins, and
Dives" is in its 35th season.
- That's a great wing. Mmm!
- [Michael] "Guy's Grocery Games"
has enjoyed almost 30 seasons,
and Fieri's face has graced scores
of other Food Network shows.
And there are plenty of
Fieri haters out there,
writing him off as all
bombast and, in Wells's words,
"a representation of going insane."
And don't forget the time
Anthony Bourdain wondered,
"How does Guy Fieri de-douche?"
But despite the haters,
Fieri's star continues
to shine brighter than
a kitchen grease fire.
Is this guy just the
result of what happens
when a can of Red Bull and a
jar of hot sauce make a baby?
Can this guy, yes, this
Guy, actually teach us a lot
about the cultural function of food?
Let's find out in this
"Wisecrack Edition":
"Guy Fieri: Deep or Dumb?"
It's no secret that Guy
Fieri is a busy dude,
and as the title of his flagship show
"Diners, Drive-Ins, and Dives" suggests,
Fieri is a champion of food
that's generally considered lowbrow.
- It is seriously too
legit to quit, though.
- And because he is genuinely psyched
to eat a jalapeno pepper popper sandwich
made by an unknown chef,
it's easy for critics
to write him off as a bombastic goofball.
That puts him in stark contrast
with his fellow Food Network stars,
who posture as serious chefs
or bastions of fine dining,
like the casual culinary queen
of East Hampton, Ina Garten,
or the ginger master of
the restaurant kitchen,
Mr. Robert William Flay.
But Fieri is a longtime
restaurateur in his own right,
and his recipes have a consistent ethos,
firmly rooted in a lack of concern
over traditional food preparations
and a passion for
inventive culinary fusion.
Aside from showing you the
Fieri tattoo over my heart,
it is difficult to overstate
what a singular presence he is
in the celebrity chef landscape.
But to truly understand
the taste of Flavortown,
it's important to assess
him in the context
of our national history
of celebrity chefs.
America wasn't always obsessed
with watching people cook
outrageous things on TV.
In fact, the act of eating
in mainstream, post-World War II America
was all about convenience and economy,
unless you were lucky enough
to have a bomb-ass Italian nona
to serve you up some rigatoni.
As French chef Jacques Pepin
described in his memoir,
in America, "food was
sustenance, full stop."
That meant lots of cheap,
highly processed eats.
But the arrival of French
cooking in mainstream America
would conjure a new cultural preoccupation
with things like food quality,
freshness, and seasonality.
The first big American
celebrity chef was Julia Child,
who brought her training
at Le Cordon Bleu back home
to teach her audience that
French dishes tasted better
than cream-of-mushroom-soup-based
casseroles.
Her act was revelatory,
showing that fancy cooking techniques
like mincing a mirepoix or deboning a duck
weren't just for the professionals.
Also, she invented shark
repellent for the Navy.
Seriously, Google it.
After her show, "The French
Chef," debuted in 1963,
public appetite for food TV mushroomed,
and from the mid-'80s to the mid-'90s,
foodie culture became a
mainstay of American life,
coinciding with the Reagan
era and the yuppie boom.
This eventually led to the
creation of the Food Network.
Founded in 1993, it boasted
hosts like Emeril Lagasse,
Jacques Pepin, and Robin Leach.
And by the time the
channel was popular enough
to host "The Next Food Network Star,"
its stable of celebrity chefs
represented something very specific.
Sure, they each had their own personality-
- Bam! Bam!
- [Michael] and areas of expertise.
But they were unified in a
vibe that dominates the network
and celebrity chef culture to this day.
They were seasoned, experienced,
and focused on elevating
the dishes they were making.
Sometimes, that means staying loyal
to the traditional
preparation methods of a dish.
Sometimes, it means adding
an unexpected fancy twist.
- I like to take something
really traditional
and do it with a twist, and I thought,
"Wouldn't it be fun to take the croutons
and put it on the outside?"
- [Michael] Or, as "Spectacular
Foodscapes" authors
Josee Johnson and Michael
Goodman would put it,
"Food media frames and
mediates what foodscapes could
and should be, how they
could and should operate,
and for whom they could and should work.
They communicate specific
food instructions via recipes,
but they also project powerful images
of what constitutes a good meal,
a worthy home cook,
and a celebrated chef."
That is to say,
food influencers set the
bar for home cooking,
and the rest of us just
try to capture their vibes.
In this context of good
meals and celebrated chefs,
it's no wonder that the discourse
around Guy Fieri has remained spicy.
We live in a culture that
assigns moral value to food.
As a result, good food can mean anything
from healthy to fancy to healthy-fancy,
and this is where Fieri
breaks the Jell-O mold.
The majority of the food
he showcases is neither low
in cholesterol or high
in its opinion of itself.
Truffle oil is supplanted by donkey sauce.
And we think that's a
crucial part of his appeal.
His only criteria for a good
meal are if it tastes...
- Aw, that's ridiculous!
- And, of course, as far as
that celebrated-chef thing goes,
we have that infamous
review, among many others,
to cast aspersion upon his credentials.
But the discourse around
Fieri doesn't stop there.
Scholar Emily Contois noted
in her book "Diners, Dudes, and Diets"
that as of spring 2020,
the food site "Eater" had
published more features
about Fieri than any other big-name chef,
be it Anthony Bourdain,
David Chang, or anybody else,
and these posts generated more than twice
as many comments than any other chefs.
So why the disparity?
We think it comes down
to the cultural context
Guy Fieri is operating within.
It's all fun and "Guy's Grocery
Games" for the hoi polloi
who think Fieri is a
cool, down-to-earth dude
they'd like to get a beer with.
But that's precisely why it's so easy
for critics to dunk on him.
He's easily defined as part
of what scholar Dwight Macdonald
would call the mass culture,
or its more sinister moniker, masscult.
That's essentially a commercialized
and totally artificial culture
popularized by the mass media.
Masscult exists in opposition
to what Macdonald calls high culture,
which he characterizes as
more of the formal things
you learn about in school,
like Shakespeare or the viola.
In the case of food,
that means high culture
is culinary school,
whereas masscult is home cooking
or picking up skills in a diner kitchen.
And while both the
masscult and high culture
can be wildly popular
among the greater public,
Macdonald argued way back in 1960,
"in the United States, the
demands of the audience,
which has changed from a
small body of connoisseurs
into a large body of ignoramuses,
have become the chief
criteria of success."
This was an exceedingly rude way
of saying that taste had been democratized
and thus was driven by the
consumer demands of the masses.
That's how McDonald's, the
restaurant, not the scholar,
has managed to serve hundreds
of billions of Big Macs
without serving a McRatatouille even once.
And when applying this framework
to television food celebrity culture,
it explains why the Food
Network airs so many hours
of Fieri content: he is exactly
what the spectator wants.
In other words, Fieri has some big
"let people like what they like" energy.
However, the irony is that
while Guy Fieri himself
might be a product of masscult,
he spends many of his on-screen hours
highlighting restaurants owned
not by millionaire celebrity chefs
or backed by groups of financiers,
but independent local
spots owned by families
and food-obsessed non-celebrities.
The implicit message seems to be
even in parts of the country
dominated by chain restaurants
and big-box stores,
there are still amazing,
unique meals to be had
if you're willing to find them.
Yet, despite being an easy target,
Guy Fieri staunchly refuses
to be anything other than what he is:
someone who loves food, his family,
and the unassuming mom-and-pop joints
that, to him, are
quintessentially American.
And when he tries their signature dishes,
whether it's a traditional
take on a club sandwich
or a modern update on
ramen, he's not trying
to change them or upgrade their fanciness
or make them ready for a photoshoot.
He takes them exactly as they are
and champions their specific flavors
and often their unique flavor profiles.
And while there are plenty
of classic chili dogs
and homemade Twinkies
to be had on "Triple D,"
it's, in a lot of ways,
remarkably inclusive.
As far as the show is concerned,
any food made in America is
quintessentially American,
especially when those cuisines originated
from other countries.
- [Guy] Greek favorites like hand-rolled,
beef-and-rice-filled grape leaves.
- [Michael] In recent
years, you're more likely
to see an interesting take on Vietnamese,
Korean, or Mexican food on "Triple D"
than you are a new iteration
of wings or burgers.
- A Greek family making tacos in Texas!
- [Michael] And bonus points
for foods that are mashups
of different cultures, like pastrami tacos
or duck confit enchiladas.
That's a situation that
Fieri loves to describe as...
- Ridiculous. Ridiculously good.
- [Michael] Fieri's staked
his brand on an attitude
of "I'm no better than
you; we just all love food.
Food is the greatest common denominator."
- Look at that meat.
Tender, flaky, pull-aparty,
super-hot-y, smolder-y, burny-mouth.
- [Michael] This is a crucial
difference between him
and most other food celebrities.
On "Triple D," his expertise
is held in reserve.
He doesn't make the rules,
and he's not here to correct anyone.
And while we might not think
of Fieri as overtly philosophical,
his sensibility towards food culture
shares something with Scottish philosopher
and legendary Edinburgh bar
patron David Hume, who said,
"Indulge your passion for science,
but let your science be human
and such as may have a direct reference
to action and society.
Be a philosopher, but
amidst all your philosophy,
be still a man."
For Hume, this meant that deep
and speculative thought was important,
but so was experiencing life,
being social, and having fun.
For him, philosophy was never meant
to be at the expense of
relating to everyday life
and, more bluntly, being a good hang.
And part of the reason
Fieri's approach works
is because he never gets
distracted by the more conceptual
and intellectual aspects
of modern food culture.
He's mostly there to chill and chow down.
Fieri's version of Hume's
quote might be, "Be a chef,
but not at the expense of
being a down-to-earth dude."
Sure, while he's there, he talks
about these supposedly lowbrow
foods in a highbrow way,
and he makes it clear he
knows his way around a kitchen
without acting like he owns the place.
And it's precisely this approach
that puts his culinary skills
somewhat in the background
so the viewer can fully revel
in the sensory experience
of eating a falafel waffle with him.
Fieri's restaurant experience
doesn't distract from the joy of eating.
He doesn't roll into
these smaller businesses
to throw his ego around,
unlike another chef we know.
- Holy (beep). Rubber, tasteless.
That's going straight to the trash.
- [Michael] And he's even hella humble.
- It's a great place.
You got great people.
This is the real diner
feel, so congratulations.
- While he might get a lot
of flack for his own brand,
most of what he's done on "Triple D"
is give a massive amount of promotion
to local spots he really believes in.
As far as Fieri is concerned,
everyone he meets is an expert
when it comes to making
their signature dishes.
And he has to show
deference to their recipes,
because Fieri himself
has built a reputation
on creating his own
unconventional menu items.
He's not a pretentious culinary scold.
He picked up most of his skills
working in actual restaurants.
He's positioned as a self-made man,
and this bolsters his public appeal
because Americans love a
bootstrapping narrative.
All of these factors
combined make us wonder
if Guy Fieri is the living,
breathing embodiment
of the ideal American.
Indeed, Fieri's devotion to
welcoming foods of all kinds
into his show's vision of America suggests
that he may be our true populist king.
As cook and author Julia
Turshen wrote for "Lucky Peach,"
"When it comes to visibility
and inclusiveness,
'Diners, Drive-Ins and Dives' succeeds.
Food allows the show to
highlight inclusivity
without being about inclusivity."
And yet, for segments of American culture
that still would call Indian food exotic,
Fieri appeals nonetheless.
As Julia Moskin wrote
in the "New York Times,"
"He has a Sarah Palin-like
ability to reach Americans
who feel left behind by
the nation's cultural,
or, in his case, culinary elite."
Except, of course,
Fieri has never claimed the
ability to see a foreign nation
from outside of his
Northern California home.
If most American celebrity
chefs teach people how
to cook elevated food by,
say, adding French techniques,
Fieri seeks to celebrate the American food
that chefs are already cooking.
Now, Fieri famously keeps mum
about his political opinions,
though he'll do arguably political acts
like fundraising nearly $25 million
on behalf of unemployed restaurant
workers or cooking meals
for volunteers fighting
California wildfires.
As Matt Schimkowitz put
it in "The A.V. Club,"
"Whether you read his
actions as philanthropic
or socialist or the end of
food culture as we know it,
Guy fits the bill.
He shows up, puts on a show,
and leaves it to his audience
to define who he is to them."
And, indeed, Fieri's able to
cash in on his keen insight
into the broader American
psyche by being everything
and anything to everyone and anyone,
regardless of background,
political affiliation,
or access to flame-printed shirts.
There's plenty of problems
with America, but ultimately,
Fieri represents all the best parts
of what the country claims to value:
inclusivity, joy, and
on-fire, out-of-bounds,
kicking, gangster, bomb flavor morsels.
And that, in our opinion, is
actually, kinda, surprisingly,
we can't believe we're
about to say this, deep.
- You hear what I'm saying?
- But what do you guys think?
Is Guy Fieri the ultimate
embodiment of American ideals,
or is he just a burger-lovin' dude
who's single-handedly kept the
hair bleach industry afloat?
Let us know in the comments.
Hit the subscribe button
like you're throwing too
much sauce on the meat,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
Thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out our
new exclusive perks on Patreon.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)